does rocket even like beta quill if you  douse it you must submit this sartorial  sign of sadness in avengers endgame in  guardians of the galaxy 2 star lord adds  a red scarf to his stylish ensemble  unfortunately he bites the dust along  with most of the guardians of the galaxy  in avengers infinity war as the  surviving member of the original team it  makes for an especially touching nod  when rocket is shown in avengers endgame  sporting the same scarf it's especially  touching because the two don't always  get along it also perhaps shows some  character growth on behalf of rocket who  was unapologetically self-centered for  most of the first two guardians films  the real question is whether rocket  actually gave the scarf back once peter  quill got resurrected after all it gets  pretty cold in space even for a raccoon  don't call me a raccoon oops sorry  rocket